bonjour
bonjour à chacun bonjour à chacune
je suis cyr
impôts est pragmatique me dit on
m'a circonstances
et d'être un créateur de circonstance
nous avons à changer notre manière
d'habiter ensemble sur la terre sur gaïa
une manière qui passe par être des
créateurs d'impact planétaire positif
et ça ensemble
une manière aussi qui passe pour chacun
de l'avoir à lettres pour être ensemble
alors bienvenue
dans un triptyque d'expérience tête
coeur et corps
avec un premier tableau
celui de la tête
de la prise de conscience
il était une fois
l'histoire d'une phrase
apparemment tout bête fait de mots du
quotidien
cette phrase
elle m'est venue
un jour de l'année de ce1 de l'une de
mes deux filles
et lina prenez le la conjugaison du
verbe être et du verbe avoir
cette phrase là voilà
plus tu as
plus c'est difficile d'être
et plus tu es
moins tu as besoin d'avoir
depuis quelques dizaines d'années la
voir nous interdit presque notre rapport
à notre être
il s'exprime puissamment dans notre
besoin de possession dans notre rapport
à l'objet
alors que depuis les peuples premiers
l'objet
est ce symbole non moins puissants de la
transmission de quelque chose qui est
par delà chacun
plus tu as plus c'est difficile d'être
et plus tu es moins tu as besoin d'avoir
cette phrase est essentielle
elle nous questionnent dans notre intime
dans notre rapport à soi mais aussi dans
notre rapport aux autres dans notre
rapport à gaïa
elle interpelle notre courage de passer
de l'avoir à l'être
alors je vous propose un premier petit
courage avec moi je vous propose juste
de fermer les yeux
d'inspirer avec moi
et de souffler
repéré un objet qui fait du bien à votre
être
qui vous reconnecte à votre être
vous le visualiser
sa forme sa couleur son odeur
ok
mon objet à moi c'est une guitare
et c'est
cette guitare et je vais pas lui faire
de l'ombre
il sera une fois
l'humidité et l'ambition réunis pour
nous permettre d'être ensemble ses
créateurs d'impact planétaire positif
quand on déménage ou quand on change de
cuisine on peut voir un intérêt à
changer le sens d'ouverture de sa porte
de frigo c'est hyper simple ces deux vis
à défaire d'un côté un cache de l'odj
inverse le tout
et pendant des semaines mon brave a
cherché à ouvrir du nouveau mauvais côté
c'est le changement le plus simple il
est individuelle
et il est physique physiquement je suis
contraint je suis aidé de développer un
nouveau reflex
alors quand il s'agit de changer notre
manière d'habiter ensemble sur gaïa
nous devons être ensemble
hyper ambitieux
et chacun hyper humble
je vous propose de re fermer les yeux
une seconde fois et d'inspirer avec moi
comme vous avez bien compris
de souffler
et de repérer
quelqu'un qui peut vous aider à changer
quelqu'un en qui vous avez confiance
est quelqu'un qui ne vous rate pas non
plus
un ami un guide
que vous lisez ou que vous podcasts et
vous le visualiser
merci
mon allié à moi
il ya seulement dix jours
subitement et malgré lui cet inventeur
de matières a contraint chacun de ses
proches a inventé une autre manière
d'être en relation avec lui
il devait être parmi vous ce soir
il est sûrement
l'une de ses étoiles avec moi
il était une fois l'histoire de deux
phrases
la première
de l'artiste jean christophe spinosi
si le verbe permet de se comprendre la
musique permet de s'aimer tout de suite
la deuxième
de jean pierre goux un éveilleur de
conscience planétaire
gaia n'a pas besoin d'être sauvé elle a
juste besoin qu'on l'aide
la musique permet de s'aimer tout de
suite
gaia a juste besoin qu'on lève
alors fermez les yeux d'une dernière
fois
inspiré avec moi
souffler
et repérer
votre musique
celle qui vous met en mouvement
vous l'entendez
vous la fredonner peut-être déjà
ma musique à moi
c'est un slam que j'ai écrit et composé
il ya un an
et vous savez quoi
j'ai trop hâte de découvrir et partager
la playlist convient de créer ensemble
non
on trouvera de moyens
dans mon triptyque d'expérience le
deuxième tableau c'est le tableau du
coeur celui de la rencontre
il y a trois mois je me suis dit
si je jouais d'une guitare fait dans une
matière écologiquement responsable qui
m'anime chaque jour le 16 décembre
et là il faut que vous partagez un truc
internet est aussi
un outil extraordinaire qui rend visible
accessible tous nos alliés
sur gaïa
internet nous connecte nous permet
d'agir ensemble c'est juste une première
de l'histoire de l'humanité
alors de cette intention à quelques mots
clés sur un moteur de recherche puis un
premier coup de fil un deuxième à
l'autre bout
c'est fred pons
un inconnu complet pour moi à ce moment
là
bonjour fred on ne se connaît pas j'ai
un truc un peu particulier à vous
partager est-ce que c'est ok pour vous
est-ce que vous avez cinq minutes
il me répond ok
je cherche un luthier pour me fabriquer
une guitare
pour jouer dans un événement dans trois
mois
trois mois ça va pas être possible mon
carnet de commandes moi il ya deux ans
aujourd'hui
évidemment
en plus c'était dans une matière pour
remplacer le plastique 100 % que de
sources et ce en concurrence avec
l'alimentation durable le truc pas
complètement simple donc
et là il réagit il me dit 'il matière
comme ça je la cherche
enfin je la cherche pas en fait parce
qu'on m'a toujours dit que ça n'existait
pas
et bien - fred je peux vous dire que
cette matière elle existe
et là j'entends sa voix qui s'anime et
il me dit
c'est fantastique
je suis en train de développer une
guitare pour réduire l'impact écologique
donc j'utilise le bois uniquement pour
le manche et la table d'harmonie
du coup le corps de la guitare je suis
en train de faire fabriquer à un moule
pour pouvoir injecter en plastique
recyclé faute de mieux et si je
comprends bien cette matière
je peux presque dire qu'elle est noble
écologiquement
oui fred tu peux le dire comme ça ça me
va plutôt bien
et fred conclu en disant c'est un espèce
de poètes qui débarque de nulle part
c'est hyper chaud le timing parce que
moi le moule au plus tôt gelé dans deux
mois si tout va bien
mais il faut qu'on tente en fait
poète oui
pragmatique aussi
et cette guitare qui était un impossible
il y a trois mois
cette guitare
je suis très heureux de vous la
présenter
et c'est une guitare qui aujourd'hui
est unique au monde
alors
j'ai fait mon objet j'ai mon allié
j'ai la musique qui me met en mouvement
donc bienvenue dans mon troisième
tableau celui du corps de la vibration
bienvenue dans cette expérience
d'un créateur d' impact planétaire
positif
[Musique]
et
m
2010neuf l'année de naissance de la
colline
me vint à défaut d'être ne va
je joue avec lui
émile 21 et quadrature du siècle
en plein vendée globe nous devons
apprendre les nouveaux vents du globe
comment trouver ses propres vents
portants
quand pourtant
évent de ce monde d'après nous
imposerait de naviguer au près
comment naviguer sans repères précis
vitesse monde d'à peu près
qui se dresse devant nous qui mousse qui
nous dresse compte entre nous
[Musique]
ce monde est devenu comme un seul
continent devenu incontinent
standardiser à ces quatres coins
toujours les mêmes causes les mêmes
magasins
dans ce monde osons le courage de passer
de l'avoir à l'être
pas être tirée à quatre épingles mais
tirait les épingles de son jeu
neymar à nous avec un chemin ils
naviguent inde estime
navigon mais aussi l estime des autres
et de soi
défrichant ce chemin sur le terrain de
jeu
aujourd'hui avec vous j'ai c'est jeu
slam je sais l'âme
on
[Musique]
mais
non
quand l'improbable surgi
accueil le questionne de transforme
je cherche deux fils getis comme amiens
2 à 0
comme le marin l'uci dit optimiste
résout toujours la vague
j'accueille à demain celle probable de
demain
les fous du réchauffement hier sont
considérés comme les sérieuses
[Musique]
je préfère être un fou d'aujourd'hui
sérieux de demain
osez être moi même ce que je regarde se
développe
aux yeux être un créateur d'impact
sanitaire
poids 1
[Musique]
fort de votre objet de votre allié de
votre musique
expérimenté
naviguer dans ce nouveau vent du club
sur vos atlantique et pacifique
découvrez toutes ces îles qui façonnent
le visage de ce siècle 21
[Musique]
s'est immergé qui émergent ces éruptions
qui font irruption
au delà des réflexions philosophiques
entre présentiel existentielle c'est
dans le démerde ancien là que la
quadrature du siècle 21
trouvera les jolis contes les bons
comptes après 2021
pour éviter d'arriver adm et construire
notre nouvel adn
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]